hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm a property investor and in this
video
i am going to be answering your
property investment questions so what do
i need you to do right now
please comment below in the video with
your
property investment questions why is
this important here's the thing
i've been in property now for 12 years
i've done over 300
property investment deals that's a deal
a deal a deal a deal a deal 300 times
now your first deal is your hardest and
i am desperate to see
you do your first deal this year 2021
so what's stopping you what's holding
you back what little lack of knowledge
do you need to have the gaps filled
for you to be able to go and do that
deal i want to know
comment below let me know what questions
you have and then i'm going to answer
your questions best i can
so do me a favor before you start
commenting as well smash the like button
also subscribe
and turn on the notification bell so
let's see what questions that we've got
from last week
we've got robert m he says hi samuel
great videos
i'm looking at rent to rent i'm curious
would it still be profitable if doing
this with houses
and then renting them out as a single
laps would this be silly
or just too risky managing voids
great question robert now just if
anyone's thinking
that they don't quite understand the
question i think what rob's saying is
rent to rent is when you rent a property
you have a management agreement where
you're paying a monthly fee to that
property
usually a reduced amount and then you
put tenants in for a much higher amount
and then the difference
minus costs is your monthly profit this
is a way of generating monthly cash flow
from a property without even owning it
it's called rent
to rent now usually when you do this
you're going to want to add value to the
property even if you don't do anything
to the property just by changing its use
so if you rent a property but then you
change its use
for example you rent it as a single let
but then
you list it on airbnb oh my goodness
really good time to do that right now by
the way
with staycations going crazy um then
you're going to push the value up
you're going to get a lot more rent and
you're going to make a lot more profit
so what robert's saying is could you
just offer reduced rent
then put in a tenant and just make maybe
100 or 200 pounds a month
um you could do it i've known people do
that
uh jm spooner one of my first ever
students
she did that successfully for a couple
years and made made a little bit of
money each month
i personally wouldn't recommend taking
on a rental rent
unless you're expected to be making a
profit of 500 pounds per month
because that way like you said if you've
got a void or a problem you've got
unexpected maintenance
you've got a little bit of buffer
whereas if you're just expecting to pay
1 or 200 pounds
it doesn't really leave you with much
profit so
uh you've got a little bit of reward but
you've still got risk
so so you just want to manage that risk
reward ratio
i hope that helps robert good luck with
all you are doing
we've got next question has come from a
guy called dazgov
dasgov great to have you on the channel
man i appreciate you being a subscriber
dad says
hi samuel thank you always educating us
which courses
of yours or any others would you
recommend that teaches
or demonstrates negotiation negotiation
um okay so all of my training programs
would teach negotiation i think pretty
much all of them
uh if it's if it's a course on joint
ventures i'm going to teach you how to
negotiate a joint venture deal
if it's lease option how to negotiate
lease option or how to negotiate
um in deal selling with investors so
every strategy
you are going to have slightly different
way of negotiating
however the biggest negotiation tip i
can say
is five words be
prepared to walk away that's the biggest
thing i'll say
so whether you're a deal sourcer and
you're trying to sell to investors
if you're trying to sell a deal to an
investor but you're desperate for the
investor to buy the deal because you've
got no other investors
you're not you're not in a strong
position to negotiate whereas if you're
trying to sell a deal to an investor
and you've got another 15 investors that
want to have a conversation with you
if this dude doesn't want to don't want
the deal then great you're in a really
strong position
you're happy to walk away hey mr
investor i don't have to sell the deal
to you i've got another 15 people
that want to speak to me so how can we
make this work
what do you want to do like strong
position
same with lease option agreements if
you're trying to secure a lease option
agreement
i i've i just actually had a message
from from jl spooner
uh jl spooner my first ever student i
mentioned literally just messaged me
10 minutes prior to this this this q a
this filming
on this q a sunday um it's actually my
here we go so she she said to me
she she she showed me a picture of some
keys
all right and i'm like i know what that
means i'm pretty sure that's the least
option agreement she's been working on
so i responded with a voice note omg
that's not the least option agreement
tell me it is i'm super excited
everything is fine in my hand let me
know when you're free
all right so she wants to chat why does
she want to chat she wants to chat to
celebrate
okay massive part of success celebrate
your success but
how did she negotiate that deal well she
was negotiating back and forth
okay and she kept messaging me we were
chatting and jl was saying the seller's
saying they want this and they want this
and they want that and i said to you
hold on
have you got any other deals in the
pipeline she said uh
not these options i said don't worry
about this deal right now
i said tell the seller what your offer
is
tell them the terms and go and find
another
few deals because you need you need to
fill your pipeline
because when you've got other stuff in
the bag or in the pipeline
you're in such a stronger position and
even if it falls through if this if the
seller doesn't go ahead or they they
don't
like your offer and they're being
unreasonable you can say that doesn't
work for me
i'm prepared to what i'm prepared to
walk away
you really are prepared to walk away but
when you're prepared to walk away you
often don't walk away you often
get the deal like jl did so i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna drink her straight
after this
maybe drive around to see the see the
house apparently she told me she's gonna
be making
three thousand pounds a month profit on
that deal
like cash flow and capital appreciation
i mean it's crazy at a lease option
agreement you don't even need to put
down a deposit
crazy okay um by the way if you're
liking the video hit the like button
don't forget to drop your question and
when you drop your question below
don't just ask a question and then leave
youtube and forget you asked it you want
to ask the question
then subscribe and turn on the
notification bell
that way when i respond and you see a q
a sunday you'll
you'll be able to watch it and hear my
answer to your question okay so
um sorea santos do you recommend an
interest only
or repayment mortgage for residential
property appreciate the content okay so
this is something that you have to make
the call i myself
much prefer buying a house and paying
the minimum
interest on the house why
why do i want to pay the mortgage off
because that's something that
most people in their minds they think
pay off the mortgage as quick as
possible
i'm gonna i'm gonna need a repayment
mortgage to pay it off
i don't want to pay it off i like debt
as long as it's good debt so if i've got
a buy to let property and i've borrowed
money from the bank
but the tenant is paying the interest
payments
and me money
then then why would i want to pay that
mortgage off
you know i i i want to i want to die
with debt
high net worth individuals are usually
also high
debt worth individuals so if i've got
good debt
i'm not rushing to pay it off and and
what what am i going to do with it
instead so
the money okay so if you've got say
you've got a repayment mortgage
you're paying a thousand pounds a month
you're paying 500 pounds a month
interest
500 pounds a month on repaying off the
debt
you're paying a thousand pounds a month
on this one house and let's say the rent
is 1200 pounds
so you've got 200 pounds left but that's
going to go on other stuff
so that property is going to make you no
money but you're paying off the debt
slowly so that in 30 years time or
whenever you'll own it
outright you could do that or
you could keep that 500 pounds back not
pay off the debt
save it until it gets to 25 grand or
something
and then use it to buy another property
and then do the same thing again and use
it to buy another property and you're
going to end up
with a bunch of properties with
mortgages on them
rather than one paid off i'd rather a
bunch of properties
with mortgages on them than one property
paid off why
because a bunch of properties means more
cash flow
which pays for my life and if you've got
lots of houses
when they go up in value which they
always do over time
give it long enough when they go up in
value you're benefiting from multiple
capital appreciations like monopoly
so that that's what i prefer repayments
okay dean kalik by the way if someone
asks a question and i answer
and then it kind of shoots another
question into your mind
just go ahead and ask it ask away in the
comment box that's what it's for
it's called the question box today hi
samuel
what should i do to avoid bad non-paying
tenants dean to avoid bad non-paying
tenants
few things number one buying an area
whereby it's not filled with bad
non-paying tenants
if you buy a house in the middle
of a red light district
and there's you know benefits street
galore
broken glass really high crime rate yeah
somewhere like let's say in liverpool
not not that liverpool's like that i
love liverpool but if you were going to
buy in
certain parts of liverpool certain parts
of like brutal
you can buy houses for like 50 50 grand
but would you want to
because you'd be left with you can't how
you're going to put
a a decent working tenant in a proper
site it's going to be
you you might on paper think i've got a
really good return on investment
i'll buy it for 50 grand and i'll rent
it out for 500 a month
but you're gonna attract the kind of
tenants
that are gonna that are gonna break the
windows
not pay their rent this isn't me being
stereotypical this is me going off
statistics i'm getting off the crime
rate
in the area it's not it's not being
judgmental
people people get all upset people
it's like it's more expensive
to have car insurance if you had a crash
previously is that being judgmental no
statistically you're more likely to have
a crush again
in fact it's more expensive to be a man
a young man than a young woman is that
sexist it's not sexist
it's statistically true proven
in the same way there's certain areas by
statistically proven that you're going
to have problems so you've got to you've
got you've got to factor in
those problem costs and then suddenly
your your return investment doesn't look
so
attractive so what's my point how to
avoid bad tenants you asked
well maybe no i wouldn't say go to
really fancy neighborhoods because then
you're going to have
really expensive houses and the rents
are going to be similar so you want to
go to areas
they've got decent people you know
working area
if a one is drug lords and prostitutes
everywhere
and a ten is where i live in beckons
field beautiful you know mansions
everywhere
you probably want to be going towards
like a three or four
um so that's area second thing is you
want to choose your tenants well
vet them well vet them get
references get previous landlord
references
um if if if they haven't got
um a good source of income because
they're first-time renters or something
like that
then maybe ask their parents to be a
guarantor you know there's lots of
things you can do
all right next i hope that helps
nobod [ __ ] hi samuel question
are you paying attention to the fact
that the property that you buy is
leasehold or freehold
does it even matter yeah it matters
a lot so you'll see if
it's a leasehold property they should
specify that on you know
the estate agent or the seller should
tell you that up front
if they don't it will get picked up when
you're buying it from the solicitors but
if it's if it's an
on market deal on rightmove it will say
leasehold or freehold
you can also check on that registry and
things like that for free
okay um let me tell you the difference
least hold you don't own the land
so if you're buying a house on land
that you not own does that mean that the
land owner could just
say i want the land back and then you'd
be left with a house that you couldn't
access
it does mean that which is terrible
however when you buy a property that's
leasehold you'll have a certain length
lease when you buy it so it might be
you've got a hundred year lease
and you're going to pay a hundred pound
a year a year
to lease the land and then you're going
to buy the property
so you might think oh well what does it
matter and
it doesn't matter that much it will sell
for cheaper it might be a little bit
harder to sell
but if you if you've got access to the
land for 100 years
you're going to be dead right so who
cares
it doesn't really matter it doesn't
really matter but if the lease is short
like 20 30 years then you've got to open
well actually number one it's going to
be a nightmare to sell
because if i buy it and try stuff no one
wants a short lease but secondly when
the lease runs out
we're gonna do so generally i stick with
freehold uh if you're if you're buying a
flat
an apartment in england it will always
be leasehold because
if you're buying an apartment in a block
you don't own the block
or the land you own the apartment so
you're leasing the rest and that's why
you'll pay
a service charge a ground rent for the
land
for the actual communal areas for the
building but you're
buying the apartment itself in scotland
flats are freehold it's a little bit
different but yeah so do take note of
leasehold versus freehold tanzakazzi
says i would like to know sir
when you join venture with the
contractor and you have
secured the piece of land cash
do you joint venture 5050 provided they
will build
and only or they do all the other
expenses
and architecture fees structural et
cetera please explain who pays for what
in the
joint venture okay so
tan dokasi joint ventures are a blank
piece of paper
it's whatever you agree with the
other party you're talking about a land
so if you're doing a joint venture
with the owner of the land like
lawton did on the financial freedom
challenge which by the way is going
really really well but if you're if you
if you're coming across a landowner
and the the person that owns the land
you're saying hey look how about
we'll build on the land um you're not
ever going to own
well you're going to keep it in their
name aren't you
so the land is going to stay in their
name you're going to do it you're going
to have a joint venture agreement
that says that you're going to get
planning permission you're going to
build
you're going to sell and then you're
going to have a an agreed price when you
sell
for the land that'll go to them and then
the profits from everything else you'll
split 50 50.
so who's gonna pay for all the bits and
bobs depends on what you agree
absolutely depends on what you agree a
joint venture is a complete blank piece
of paper there's no right or wrong
this is where negotiation comes in
you're going to negotiate whatever you
can do but
um if i'm putting in all of the you know
the expertise the build and all that i
mean for a start you're going to you're
probably going to get development
finance to actually do the build
so you're going to borrow the money to
and you're going to get
you're going to borrow the money against
what against the land
so if the land is unencumbered meaning
there's no
existing loans or charges against the
land
you're just going to take the land joint
venture great
it's in their name and then you're gonna
advise your joint venture partner that
you're gonna be getting
a development finance loan there'll be a
charge on the land which is gonna pay
for the entire build
in terms of who's going to pay for the
professional fees
it's whatever you work out okay last
question
i hope you enjoyed this video by the way
every sunday i do this
i've been doing this i don't know how
long now maybe a year
two years if you enjoy it hit the like
button connor says
i hope you're well how much roughly is
needed to set up a fully compliant deal
sourcing business
connor to set up a fully compliant deal
sourcing business
probably about 1500 pounds depends what
you're including in the business
if you're including a website and
business cards and
logo designer depends how it just
depends how much you pay but the
absolute necessity is maybe about 1500
pounds but i wouldn't do it
you don't need to pay anything to start
a deal sourcing business
and we teach this other deal selling
masterclass to start with
i'd find deals find other existing deal
sourcing companies
i'd say hey i've got some deals do you
want to sell them to your investors
through your insurance
to your list using your fancy logo
i'll just bring the deal and we can
split the profit somehow
and do that a couple times and then use
that money to then set up your business
that way there's no money down i mean i
got a lot of businesses i've got a lot
of
properties i've created a lot of wealth
and every one of my businesses has been
started with no money people think you
need
a lot of money to start a business you
know i'll go to the bank and i'll get a
business loan to start my business
you don't need to do that you don't need
money to start a business
you don't need money to start a property
business
what you need is you need creativity you
need a network
you need knowledge you need courage
a lot of stuff but you don't need money
i hope that helps thank you so much for
watching drop your questions in the
question box
below and i look forward to seeing you
next week hit the like button
subscribe thanks for watching see you
next time